I would like to please welcome our new
bachelorette
Jojo after weeks of speculation Joelle
Jojo Fletcher was announced as the new
bachelorette during Monday's after the
final rose special the real estate
developer gushed with excitement over
the chance to find her one true love
congratulations you are the Bachelorette
fans speculated second runner-up Kayla
Quinn was the one who had actually
scored the gig a source confirms two et
both girls filmed their introductions
and packages but the decision to go with
Jojo was made at the very last minute I
mean guys I'm so excited you're gonna be
phenomenal good choice
cheers to a new season of our favorite
dating show featuring plenty of romantic
and dramatic moments hopefully with
these guys JoJo's unforgettable older
brothers who essentially put Bachelor
Ben through the ringer he's not as
emotionally invested in it as you are
Ben you brainwashed these girls way too
much man
the new season of The Bachelorette
begins filming in LA on Tuesday